when you realize how unlikely it is that
collections of particles would
come together to yield a living system
called a human being and how spectacular
it is that this collection of particles
called a human being
can invent manufacture notions of value
and meaning and purpose how spectacular
is that
brian green welcome to the show thank
you
thank you for being here i am a massive
fan of your work i'm very very glad that
you're joining me today
oh thank you it's great to hear we hear
a lot about the big bang and the
beginning of the universe
13 and a bit billion years ago but i
want to start at the end
have you got any predictions for the end
of the universe if the big bang is when
time began
then when will time stop
well we don't know but there certainly
are ideas that people have developed so
it's not as though we're just shooting
in the dark
the most straightforward interpretation
of the data and the mathematics suggests
that the universe may
continue to expand forever
forever is a kind of funny concept it's
an idea where
time wouldn't literally end but enroute
to that eternity
everything that we know about will end
every star will end every galaxy every
planet
matter itself will according to some
of our cutting-edge theories
disintegrate into a spray of
more refined particles electrons
neutrinos
that will just continue to waft through
that ever expanding cosmos
so we don't know that that's how things
will end up
but if you were to ask me to place bets
based on what we know today and what
we've observed today
that would probably where the bulk of my
money would go is that what's referred
to as the big freeze
it is because the universe will just
continue to get
ever colder as it gets ever larger
and weirdly enough it's also referred to
as the heat death
it seems to be a kind of tension between
the big freeze and the heat death
but they're actually the same thing
because the idea is that you'll reach
a kind of equilibrium where every place
in the universe will come to the same
temperature
and it's that equal distribution of heat
that is
what we refer to with the heat death but
but the temperature the common
temperature will be so low
that you can also think of it as a kind
of big freeze
what is a way that people can wrap their
heads around how
far away from us that is now
uh it's a tough one i i have a metaphor
that i like to use
when taking people on a journey toward
the far future i use
the empire state building in manhattan
where i envision that every floor
is 10 times the duration of the previous
floor and this sort of
poetic representation so the ground
floor is one year the next floor 10 the
next floor 100
so it's an exponential scale where
10 to the floor number is representing
the year that you're on at a given floor
and that approach takes you to 10 to 100
years into the future
today we're 10 to the 10 years from the
big bang
so we're on the 10th floor so everything
that we know about from the big bang
till today
only gets to the 10th floor and
exponentially far
into the future as you climb now by the
time you reach 10 to 100 years into the
future
we'd be enroute if the ideas that we
currently have are correct we'd be
enroute toward that heat death
we'd be in route toward that big freeze
but again
if it keeps on going forever then even
the hundredth floor of the empire state
building 10 to 100 years in the future
at some point that will be a mere blink
of an eye and root to
the time scales that will ultimately
encounter
so it's hard to have a metaphor it's
hard to have an image but i think the
empire state building and that
exponential growth at least takes you
part way
toward the incredibly long time skills
that we're talking about here
what are the final things that are going
to be around there is it
black hole decay is it little
um fluctuations in space-time what's
left
yeah so black hole and black hole decay
which is an idea that comes from stephen
hawking that's really what made stephen
hawking stephen hawking he realized that
black holes are not forever right you
would think that if a black hole i think
is everybody's familiar
if it's always pulling in more material
and getting bigger and bigger as it
swallows up
stars and planets and things in its
environment
you'd think that a black hole might just
last forever
but hawking realized that black holes
can also
evaporate particles can actually escape
a black hole through certain quantum
processes
and if you wait long enough every black
hole will disintegrate
through this dissipation into particles
and indeed by 10 to 100 years into the
future in fact that's why the empire
state building analogy is
really well suited basically all black
holes
by that point will have just evaporated
and they will have given off these
particle sprays that will waft through
the void
so when you ask what will be left in the
far future even black holes will not be
left as far as we
know we suspect that all black holes
will be gone so the only thing that will
be left
will be the most refined the most stable
elementary particles around maybe
refined is the wrong word it's really
stability that matters
and so these particles will be wafting
through the darkness
and then you're right there will be
quantum fluctuations that's
what i mean so quantum mechanics that's
still around
in terms of a governing law will allow
small
energetic fluctuations to appear
disappear
and sometimes those fluctuations might
be large they're
more rare if they're large but if you
have
infinite time on your hands then rare
things can happen
and so rare fluctuations where
particle collections and energetic
collections
momentarily form stick around for for
some period of time and then dissipate
that can happen too
and root to eternity so if you wait long
enough some
weird things can happen because weird
things can fluctuate out of nothingness
that's something i took away from
reading your book that when you
scale things up either in terms of time
or space
you get some incredibly odd outcomes
there's only a there's a relatively
finite number of
combinations of how you could piece
particles together within the volume of
space that you make up
right which is one of the reasons that
people think if the universe is infinite
that there's essentially an infinite
number of brines and
and chris is having slightly altered
versions of this conversation
yeah that's a very strange idea but one
that naturally comes out of the
mathematics it's again one of those
ideas that it's hard to
fully internalize because it's so
bizarre but
if space as you say does go on
infinitely far
so not in a temporal quality but in the
spatial direction which is
i think if you were to survey most
physicists who think about this and say
does it go on forever does space go on
forever
i think the the reaction among the
majority would be it does go on forever
is that right i think that's really
where the the the general zeitgeist
is when it comes to thinking about the
grand expanse of space
and you're absolutely right so in any
given finite volume
of that space there's a finite amount of
energy
a finite number of distinct ways in
which that energy can be manifested
in terms of particle configurations and
so if space goes on infinitely far
there aren't enough distinct
configurations to continue to
populate those different regions with a
different configuration of particles the
particle arrangement
has got to repeat and if it repeats
then the universe as we know it would
repeat
we are just collections of particles you
and i right so if the
configuration repeats you and i are out
there too as you're suggesting
and we're out there even more times with
slight variations
on the reality that we know about
so maybe you know i've got i've got the
show and i'm interviewing you
you know that that kind of thing would
happen out there so
so yeah i mean these these bizarre ideas
are not just
flights of fantasy they do emerge from
the laws of physics
under certain modest assumptions like
space goes on
infinitely far if that's the current on
trend
idea amongst physicists are they talking
about
the universe with matter beyond the
observable universe or are they talking
about
some sort of structure beyond a universe
our universe that is outside of the
observable universe
both both and again i'm i'm
i guess maybe i spoke too quickly i
don't want to
speak for my colleagues they may like do
a survey
and say hey brian green you're wrong
right the vast majority of us don't
think in this way but
it is the case that a commonly held
notion is that number one space can go
on
perhaps infinitely far in which case you
would have these other
domains of reality that are contiguous
with ours right and that's that first
version of
other stuff beyond the horizon beyond
the observable universe
but the common view
for cosmologists today is that a theory
called inflation
inflationary cosmology may well be
the explanation for the big bang so what
banged in the big bang is a big question
and there's a proposal on the table that
there's a certain kind of fuel
called the inflaton field and the energy
in that fuel may have driven
a period of repulsive gravity that
pushed everything apart
and if that's the case the interesting
conclusion is the math shows that it's
virtually impossible
to use up all the fuel which means that
the fuel that
gave rise to our big bang would
be left over there'd be some left over
to yield other big bangs
and those big bangs would leave over
some fuel which would drive yet further
big bangs and that's that second version
of beyond that you're referring to those
big bangs would
would be outside the domain
of reality that we would think about
even if we're allowing space to go on
infinitely far
you might think well if it goes on
infinitely far then that must exhaust
everything right i mean there can't be
something beyond the infinite
of space going on infinitely far but
that isn't correct
the weirdnesses of space and time allow
for our
domain to be infinitely large and yet
there to still be other big bangs giving
rise to other
realms which themselves can be
infinitely far so yeah kind of
infinity of infinities did it take time
for you to dispense with the common
person
all of the assumptions that me and
everybody that's listening
has when we're talking about this stuff
that you're having to remind us
about the biases that we come into this
our lack of capacity to understand what
infinity is and
stuff like that time scales is there
like some sort of deprogramming
that advanced physicists and
mathematicians go through some sort of
like onboarding camp
that they need to go through to get rid
of that thinking pattern
yeah in fact it's not even as easy as
you suggest
i think it's a lifetime of reprogramming
i mean our intuitions
are built up from the very same
experiences that everybody else has in
everyday life
where you know there's a beginning a
middle and an end to things
you know there's a finite size to things
there's a finite lifetime
to things right since that's how we live
that's how
our intuition has been built up and it's
more than just the intuition of a given
lifetime
we have behavioral perspectives and
predilections that
emerge from our own deep physiology our
brain
patterns our brain structure the the
details of our dna
all of these things carry an imprint of
our collective experience across
thousands of generations
and our forebears wandering around the
african savannah they had the
everyday experiences that matter to
survival
and yet when we go beyond the everyday
experiences and examine the quantum
realm
we examine the relativistic realm the
cosmological realm
everything that our math some of which
has been confirmed by observations
tells us is that the everyday
experiences are not a good guide
to how the world actually works so we
are in a lifetime as a physicist
a lifetime of tension between what we
experience
collectively as a species and what we
learn about the universe through
observation
isn't it interesting that the
consciousness that we have maybe it's
there so that we can correctly predict
what other people are thinking so that
we're more social beings or maybe it's
there for
any one of a number of other
explanations for our consciousness is
here
isn't it insane that one of the
byproducts of that
is that it's given us this capacity to
be able to
start to grasp at infinities to be able
to
push the limits of something if we were
not designed to think about this
and yeah we've gone beyond our design
specs it's we've all
we've overclocked our brains the same
way that computer hackers overclock
their computers
we've overclocked our brains the same
way that a light gives off light but as
a byproduct it gives off heat
maybe this is because it's given us this
particular structure of things to do one
service social animals whatever it might
be
that's also just got this slight side
effect and you guys
in your industry are just leveraging
that
and twisting that as hard as possible
yeah no i think there's
i think there's a version of that idea
that applies
to many fields but i think it is most
pronounced
for physics and mathematics i mean what
what we do is as mathematically oriented
scientists physicists
we seek out patterns in the world right
that's what we do we are pattern
recognition machines
that take in the world and try to find
the regularities
and by encapsulating those regularities
in mathematical equations we're then
able to go
even further in our understanding now
clearly
pattern recognition served us well in
the ancestral
environment i mean those of our
ancestors who knew where to go the next
day
to get the food those who knew what was
going to happen
when there was you know thunder and
lightning and recognize the
pattern that that was the signal to seek
shelter right
those of our forebears who could catch
the patterns
had a leg up in the battle for survival
and therefore pattern recognition became
intrinsic to what we do but you're right
we are pushing
that capacity well beyond the needs of
survival and trying to find patterns and
things that just don't seem to matter
to our everyday survival right i mean
you don't need to know about the big
bang
or the the weirdness of the electrons
magnetic moment
you know or quantum tunneling or quantum
entanglement
or inflationary cosmology or the
infinities of space you don't need to
know that stuff to survive and you can
make an argument
that those of our forebears who did
think about these things
perhaps they're the ones that actually
were the ones that got eaten
right i mean if you if you sat down on
the african savannah to contemplate the
schrodinger equation and quantum
evolution of electrons you didn't notice
you know the the the lion that was about
to eat you
right you know so so you could even say
that it goes against survival but
but we've gotten to a place in the
modern world
where we've got the luxury to do things
that
do not help us in the ways that pattern
recognition was initially meant to help
us
and it takes us to some pretty weird and
wonderful places
it's so fascinating that for a long time
the environment
shaped our evolution because it caused
the evolutionary forces
that required us to become fitness
adapting creatures but now that we shape
our environment
we are shaping what we will evolve and
adapt
into in the future i often think about
how evolution at the moment when the
world is changing as quickly as it is
is basically pointless because if you
did get a slight genetic mutation
whatever environment it grew up in that
was adaptive
by the time that it then passed that on
to its children
it wouldn't be useful anymore well it's
not completely true you would you might
think that and there is certainly
controversy on this point
but there are some researchers who claim
that
there is real world evolution that we
can measure
and see today they claim for instance
that
the heights of certain males in certain
parts of the world
is growing over time because females
are selection selecting males based on
height and so there's a small
differential in
the reproductive yield
among males that are taller seeding the
world with
uh you know for someone like me average
height you kind of like
go off to the corner and hang your head
low when you hear that kind of data
but uh but but but the other side of it
though
is it's not only that we are shaping the
environment that
then is back reacting on our own
evolutionary progression
we're interceding in
the evolutionary process itself so it
used to be that
mutations were these randomly occurring
events
and those that happened to enhance our
ability to survive
and reproduce were the ones that hung
around and the mutations that
didn't do that they quickly died away
but now
you don't just have mutations from
random events we're going in
and we're affecting the human genome
directly i mean this or
this is only going to become ever more
prevalent toward the future
uh and look there there there are
clearly some very powerful
things that we can do with that i mean
look at the thing that we're dealing
with right now right the corona virus so
now we have vaccines
that have been manufactured according to
the techniques that allow us to
get in and have a molecular control
over certain kinds of nucleic acids
right so so so it's powerful but it also
suggests
that when we start to do these
manipulations on human beings which are
already we're doing
that's going to have its own
evolutionary trajectory
that will be somewhat different from the
one that has been in control
for you know millions of years yeah
we're not just
cargo aboard spacey humanity how we were
crew as well
yeah exactly contributing to the
direction how do you explain
time to people as a phenomenon
well i think most people have an
intuition about time so the battle is
to leverage that intuition and convince
people that
the things that they hold dear about
time some qualities
are correct with some quality sciences
revealed to just
not not be the right way of thinking
about things so most of us have a sense
that time for you time for me time for
everybody else is basically the same
the time elapses at the same rate
regardless of what you're doing where
you are the gravity you're experiencing
the motion that you may be executing
that's plain wrong right i mean einstein
taught us
now in 1905 what are we now 2021 or
something so
you know i can't subtract but what 115
116 years ago
he showed us in the most direct way that
that's just not correct
if you're in motion your clock ticks off
time at a different rate compared to
somebody
who relative to you is at rest if you're
near the edge of a black hole
time elapses for you at a different rate
compared
to someone not experiencing that
gravitational field that's an extreme
example
but to go back to the empire state
building if you're at the top of the
empire state building your watch is
taking off time a little more quickly
than the clock of someone on the ground
on 34th street and fifth avenue
that sounds crazy but that is how time
actually works so i find that if you
take people
sequentially through these new qualities
of time that are unintuitive we haven't
directly experienced them and then
explain experiments i mean literally
people took atomic clocks put one on the
tarmac put one on
on an airplane and flew that plane
around the world
and then they compared the clocks when
that airplane landed
and these incredibly precise atomic
clocks did not agree
and it wasn't because the plane was kind
of jostling the clock it wasn't like
it's a smooth ride smooth sailing
and yet because that clock was in motion
and experiencing a different
gravitational field because it was up in
the
air compared to the clock on the surface
of the earth gravity gets a little
weaker up there a little further from
the center
the clocks ticked off time differently
there it is so so
that explains the weirdness of time but
what about it as a fundamental
phenomenon
what is it what does it do which
phenomenon sorry it's time
i don't know what time is i wish i could
tell you
that's the weirdest thing at all right
so we can measure this quality
of the world call time we can measure it
to incredible accuracy
and when we do that we can reveal
features of time that are unexpected you
know ticks off at different rates in
different environments
but if you ask me what is it that you
are measuring
i don't know i mean people have
struggled to give an answer one answer
is well
time is that quality of the world that
allows
change to take place okay again you can
sort of figure that that sort of makes
sense uh
time is that quality of the world that
ensures that
everything doesn't happen all at once
okay yeah kind of but does that really
fill you with a deep sense of
understanding of what
time itself is it doesn't do it for me
and and so i think many of us suspect
that the next revolution and
understanding will be one where
we can finally give a deeper
explanation and and there are some who
suggest and
my own field string theory is starting
to give evidence for this some think
that part of the reason we're unable to
give a
real compelling definition of time is
because time itself is not as
fundamental
as we might have thought that there's a
deeper level of reality
where we'll find that time is made up of
something
finer something more fundamental i mean
you look at any piece of matter
and if i ask you like what is i don't
know what is what is wood
you can start to give me some answers
but they may not be that compelling but
then if you get down to the molecules
and atoms
and you talk about the atoms that make
up the molecules that make up the wood
and you talk about the protons and the
neutrons in the nucleus
and the electrons and you talk about the
quarks inside of the protein
now you get to a place where like oh
okay i get it
that's like the the most basic
ingredient you put that together
and if you put it together in the right
way you get wood
i i could sort of get that and maybe the
same thing with time
so maybe the time is made up of some
molecule
i put that in you know air quotes i
don't really know what that means that
that molecule of time may be made up of
atoms of time again air quartz i don't
really know what that means
but but if we could identify those
fundamental constituents
then we could say and if they come
together in the right way
voila you get time and if we could do
that we can't yet
but when and if we can do that i think
that would give us
that deeper sensation that we more fully
understand
what it is we're talking about when we
invoke the word time that's so cool
that's awesome can you talk about the
relationship between
entropy and evolution that you go
through in your book i thought this was
absolutely fascinating yeah i'd be happy
to do that and uh as you see me
bobbing back and forth i clearly didn't
calculate the angle of the sun
yourself around if you need to remind me
whatever position i sit
but uh yeah so so i like to think about
the unfolding of reality as this kind of
interplay between these two conceptual
frameworks one of which is the drive
toward ever greater
disorder which is encapsulated by this
notion of entropy and
perhaps people have heard of the second
law of thermodynamics which
gives us a nice mathematical and
intuitive understanding
of why objects and things and situations
tend to go from order toward
disorder that move from an orderly
environment to a more disorderly
environment which we can frame
mathematically that's what the second
law of thermodynamics
encapsulates so that's a kind of
breaking down a withering away a
disintegration
the flip side which is entropy
is a force that drives things to get
ever more
refined structure when you have a battle
among living systems or even before that
battle among chemical systems
where those configurations
that are best adapted to their
environment
are the ones that are going to win that
are going to prevail you can see a drive
toward ever greater nuance and
refinement
because the more refined you are the
better adapted you are the better chance
you have of
surviving and so you kind of have these
two forces at work
entropy tends to drive toward
disintegration
evolution tends to drive toward ever
more
refined configurations and you can trace
these two forces right through the
evolution of the universe from just
after the big bang evolution we tend to
think about at the level of living
systems but as i
mentioned once a molecule learns how to
make copies of itself to replicate
those molecules that can replicate
faster swifter with greater economy and
stability
those molecules are going to win in the
sense that they're going to be able to
grab in
more raw materials from the environment
and make more copies of themselves
so this drive toward increased
refinement
that evolution by natural selection
gives us is something that has been with
us
even before living systems living
systems are an interesting
development along that evolutionary
trajectory
and so there is this interplay and you
can trace it from the big bang till
today and what i do in the book is i
trace it also from today
arbitrarily far into the future where
again we see these forces at work
guiding what takes place as we walk that
trajectory toward eternity
is it fair to say that humans locally
reverse entropy then
in a sense yes but you have to be very
careful
with what you mean by that i like to
think of it as
a kind of entropic dance that i've given
a name
it's called the entropic two step and
what i mean by the entropic two step
is the second law and you hear the word
law
you're like okay then it has to always
be true that's not even completely true
the second law is a little bit different
what the second law says is that
there's an overwhelming likelihood
that overall entropy and disorder will
go up
but that doesn't prevent entropy and
disorder from going
down in some regions so long as there's
a compensating amount of entropy that
goes up in the wider world
and that's the two step entropy can go
down over here
so long as it goes up over there in some
surrounding region and so human beings
sure we constantly force entropy to go
down we've
constantly forced order to go up in our
local environment but when you look
very carefully at the detail process
by which we force entropy to go down
there's always entropy that's generated
heat and waste that is generated that we
expunge
to the wider environment so we can
maintain
order for a while because we can cause
disorder to be emitted outside
but sooner or later entropy does catch
up with us so it's a local phenomenon
that we can carry on
with for a period of time ultimately we
lose that entropic battle
i remember speaking to adam frank on the
show and he was talking about how one of
the universals he thought
we would find with any intelligent
civilizations on other planets
would be an increase in heat would be
some sort of global warming
because inevitably when you try and
wrangle the environment to do what you
want it to do
whatever that is you're going to give
off these waste products
yeah yeah uh so adam i agree with that
statement
and it actually goes back to a statement
of uh albert einstein so albert einstein
once said that
he viewed all understanding of the
universe as provisional
right theories come along they get
developed they get replaced he even
viewed his own general theory of
relativity as provisional
that one day it would be replaced but he
said when it comes to the second law of
thermodynamics
he said i don't view that one as
provisional i view that one as one that
will always be with us
and indeed the second law by virtue of
saying that entropy
goes up means that heat will ultimately
always be generated by any system
and certainly a civilization of
intelligent beings
who want to preserve order in their
local environment
they will only be able to do that at the
expense of generating heat that wafts
outwards
and so yes that is a a general tendency
and you might ask
so why was einstein so confident about
this
idea and that takes us a little far
afield so i won't try to go into the
detail but i'll simply note that
when you look at how you establish the
second law of thermodynamics it doesn't
involve
really any detailed math or complex
ideas it's simply the statement that
there are
more ways for a system to be disordered
more ways for its ingredients to be
arranged
that will be characterized as disordered
compared to the number of ways
that those ingredients can be arranged
to look orderly
so it's simply a counting of the number
of configurations of the particles
and there's an overwhelmingly large
number that yield disordered systems
very few relatively speaking that yield
ordered system i mean you know this
you go into a kid's bedroom right
it's a mess usually because it's just so
much more likely that the ingredients
the good the
games the books the toys will be in a
disordered arrangement it takes a very
careful arrangement of the ingredients
to look orderly
and that's in a nutshell why einstein
had such confidence in the second law of
thermodynamics
because of a toddler's bedroom toddler's
bedroom that's all it was that was the
inspiration
but you draw a line between entropy and
thought and this impermanence of thought
as well you take us through that
yeah you know so if you push these ideas
even further
and you say to yourself look any
physical system of any sort has to
generate heat
to preserve its own inner order if you
take that as a as a given
and as i said they're very simple basic
arguments that lead us to that play
then you can say to yourself look let me
consider a thinking system
any thinking system regardless of what
it might be a human brain
a computer a weird thing in the far
future that we can't imagine right now
that's able to think
any thinking system in order to have
thought
must generate heat because it's a
physical process
and if you follow that through into the
far future of the cosmos you find
that in the far future about the 50th
floor of the empire state building to go
back to our little analogy 10 to 50
years into the future
a thinking system that generates heat
the universe will not be able to absorb
that heat it will not be able to take
that heat in at a sufficiently fast rate
which means that any thinking system in
the far future if it thinks
one more thought it will burn up
it will fry in the heat generated by the
entropy produced by the very process of
thought itself
and that comes to the weird conclusion
then that thought
will come to an end thought itself is a
product of physical processes that
cannot be sustained indefinitely in the
universe
isn't that fascinating that thinking
is the thing which allows us to get the
insight into how the universe works
it's also the process by which we may be
able to
slow down some of the processes that
would lead to our destruction
but ultimately it is the cause of
our destruction yeah yeah it is funny
how
you know the snake eats its own tail you
know once again
you know um and you can even say it
it's also kind of remarkable that
through the process of thought we can
understand
that this is the fate that awaits the
problem what's the tale going into your
own mouth predict it happening yeah
yeah yeah and there's nothing you can do
to sort of
divert that tail from entering the mouth
there's no way that
you can subvert the physical processes
that ultimately
will spell our own destruction i've read
some stephen baxter sci-fi
and in those he likes to play around
with alien civilizations very very far
into the future
and one of the propositions that he puts
across is
these civilizations would basically
upload themselves into some form of
computer
and then put themselves to sleep until
the universe is significantly colder
and then they would be able to run their
operations and it wouldn't get so hot
i'm guessing that's something you've
come across as well yeah in fact it goes
back
to insights of a famous physicist named
freeman dyson
who sadly passed away not too long ago
he played a key role in the early
developments of quantum mechanics and
had all sorts of
interesting creative ideas and one that
he had was
exactly what you're suggesting that
perhaps a living system
a civilization could preserve
its existence by going through long
periods of hibernation
so they think a couple thoughts and then
they go to sleep
and allow the heat generated by those
thoughts to dissipate
and it may take a long time for the heat
to dissipate in the far future when the
universe is you know very cold and
things are moving very slowly
but then they'll wake up and they won't
even know they've been asleep
because they weren't thinking while they
were asleep right
so they will wake up and they'll have
another couple thoughts
and then they go back to sleep and allow
those thoughts to dissipate
and in that way freeman dyson thought he
had established
a strategy by which any living system
could
exist forever but what he didn't know
at the time was that our universe
is not just expanding it's accelerating
in its expansion
this is a discovery in 1998 that won the
2011 nobel prize
and if you take that idea seriously and
imagine that the universe will continue
to
speed up in its expansion then it turns
out that dyson's
argument doesn't quite work and the
reason it doesn't work is because
there's a source of heat that the
accelerated expansion gives rise
to and that source of heat permeates the
universe permeates space
and it's that heat that prevents the
universe from
absorbing the additional heat that a
thinking system would generate through
the process
of thought and when you take all that
into account you see that
living systems cannot live forever
unfortunately or maybe fortunately
depending on your perspective
yeah what's a boltzmann brain
a boltzmann brain is kind of a weird
fluctuation of a particle configuration
going back actually to the very first
question
that you asked me when we started this
conversation so in the far future
there will just be these particles
wafting through the void governed by
quantum mechanics and and every so often
and route to eternity those particles
can kind of bang into
each other in an interesting way it
won't happen often because these
particles are mostly isolated
but again if you're waiting infinitely
long times
or arbitrarily long finite times
weird things can happen and one of the
weird things is particles can bang into
each other
and create or recreate a human brain out
there in the void
and that brain floating in the void can
have a thought
or two and these are called boltzmann
brains ludwig boltzmann
he didn't actually describe these things
but using his ideas
physicists of more recent vintage
have developed this idea and the weird
thing is
imagine that that brain floating in the
void just happens to have
exactly the same particle configuration
as my brain does right now
right you might say well that's rare and
i said yeah it's rare but and route to
eternity it's going to happen
rare things will happen with essentially
probability one
so that brain floating in the void is
going to think it's me
it's going to have my memories because
my memories are just configurations of
particles inside my head
right it's going to have my personality
my personality is just the configuration
of particles inside of my head
so that brain out there in the void it's
literally going to be me
saying oh my god how did i get here
what am i doing you know floating out
here in the void
um and that's kind of a weird a weird
idea
and and the reason we come to this it's
not like for you know some kind of
comedic turn or something
the reason we we think about this idea
is because
you have to ask yourself what is the
most likely way
that a thinking system such as of
ourselves comes to be
and you come to a weird conclusion when
you invoke boltzmann brains because
there's only one biological brain that
we know of that's going to say be
me right because there isn't enough time
for multiple me's to form in the natural
biological way but because eternity is
so
far along boltzmann brains and my brain
forming
via this boltzmann random manner that
can happen arbitrarily many times
and root to eternity and so will happen
arbitrarily many times so they're going
to be like a gazillion brian greens
floating in the void if you can think
about all of time
and only one of me that forms in the
biological manner so if you ask me
like who am i and where am i how do i
get to be
a dispassionate look at the numbers
would lead me to say
i'm a boltzmann brand that i just formed
in the void and the conversation that i
thought that we'd been having for
whatever the last half hour or so
it didn't really happen it's just a
configuration of particles inside my
head making me think that i've been
having a conversation with chris
williamson
but in reality i just formed right now
with those memories of fake things that
never actually occurred
it's kind of a weird place to get to wow
that's
almost weird but even further the even
weirdness is
it winds up being a self-defeating
conclusion because
the only reason we even anticipate the
possibility of boltzmann brains is
because
of our understanding of the laws of
physics quantum mechanics and cosmology
and we extrapolate
but if boltzmann brains are real then
my recollection of having learned
quantum mechanics
and having learned general relativity
that's also false
and the data that i thought supported
quantum mechanics and
general relativity and because that's
also just a fiction of the particle
configuration of my brain right now
so so so so it winds up being a
self-defeating
conclusion where you kind of come to a
skeptical
nightmare where you can't trust anything
at all so most physicists
who take these ideas seriously are not
really envisioning that we're boltzmann
brains rather we use it as a kind of
diagnostic tool
to interrogate our theories and
hopefully we believe we'll come to a
point which we've not reached yet
where we'll be able to suppress this
possibility of boltzmann brains
getting our confidence back in the laws
of physics as usually configured
but as yet i would say we're not we're
not quite there so this is really a a
moment
of physics in progress as we try to
eliminate this
this possibility of boltzmann brains but
we have not fully done so as yet
boltzmann brain is still on the menu
still on them
yeah it reminds me a little bit of the
simulation hypothesis
this kind of like root and then a number
of different
child universes or child experiences
that could be going on
yeah no it's very similar you know this
idea that we might be
whatever like in the matrix or something
that we are just a simulation on some
futuristic super computer
um and it's a similar kind of set of
considerations where
if we ever are able to create conscious
beings in a simulation then they will
follow the same trajectory as with
boltzmann brands and say look
there are a gazillion simulations that
can be run
but there's only one real universe that
actually formed
and therefore it's overwhelmingly likely
that we're in a simulation just by sort
of counting the numbers just by the laws
of of probability
and that that's also a weird one and how
do you get out of that one well maybe
you don't maybe we
truly are simulated beings and maybe
just have to bite the bullet and accept
that
or nick bostrom who's the guy who first
came up with this simulation argument
out of oxford you know he says well
maybe any sufficiently advanced
civilization that could simulate
conscious beings on a computer they also
develop weaponry maybe they go hand in
hand and they blow themselves up
and so you never get to that to that
place or
some suggest maybe the universe comes to
an end before boltzmann brains or before
simulations actually arrive on the scene
that's a possibility too
right again we talked about one way in
which the universe could continue to
develop and evolve effectively for
eternity but it's not the only idea
about the far future
there are other theories that suggest
maybe the universe expands for a while
then collapses in on itself
a big crunch the big crunch could wipe
everything out before boltzmann brains
even have a chance of forming
it's so good it's so good do many
physicists
encounter existential crises when they
start to think incredibly deeply about
this sort of stuff
i mean some have you know i mean ludwig
boltzmann the boltzmann of boltzmann
brains you know
he died by his own hand did he really
die by suicide now look
i don't want to be armchair psychologist
and nobody else can we don't know what
was going on inside his head that day
and uh
it was in trieste italy i believe was
1905 1906.
he sent his uh wife and family i can't
remember how many kids maybe one or more
out and when they came back they found
him hanging you know
um so you know was that some other
you know just mental illness that that
was driving i don't know but certainly
he was confronted with these weird ideas
he's confronted with the physics
community that didn't accept a lot of
his ideas
that certainly may have contributed to
it um
but in terms of you know otherwise
stable physicists who go to a dark place
because of their
realizations in physics i don't know
that many
i do know some and i i don't want to get
too
hyper personal here but i certainly am
one of those that on occasion has found
myself in a less than happy place
a dark place by by taking in these
ideas in a really full sense
my sense and again i don't want to speak
for the community so
i can only give you my personal sense
and and experience of the community
is that most physicists don't take these
ideas in at a at a fully emotional level
some do
don't get me wrong some do but many just
see it as a mathematical game
where what we're trying to do is have a
better
explanation of that piece of data a
better explanation of the expansion of
space
better explanation of stellar processes
that yield
heat and light and spectra that we can
measure with great precision
and so if you view it just as sort of a
game
of symbols that you write down trying to
understand the external world
then that's it you just play the game
you enjoy it if you're lucky you come up
with some equation that
explains something it gets you a trip to
stockholm
you know you meet the royalty there and
so forth and if it's just that game
then that's the level at which you take
it in but
i don't do physics for that reason not
that i wouldn't mind getting a nobel
prize don't get me wrong
but what i'm saying is i do physics
because
i want to understand reality i mean i
really
want to understand reality and so for me
these ideas are not
just about making a better prediction or
or maybe being used for a better gadget
if you can
apply these ideas to me it's about what
can this tell us about
the universe reality and how we fit into
this grand cosmic
schema and if you take it in that way
then for instance to learn that all
structure will disintegrate to learn
that thought itself will come
to an end to realize that your life is
this
momentary blip on this cosmological
landscape most of which is not inhabited
by thinking creatures at all most of
which is not inhabited by
complex structures because they've all
disintegrated when you really take that
in fully yeah it can take you to a dark
place
i can tell you that for sure i have some
friends
who are nurses student doctors
recently qualified doctors and i asked
them
the question as well do you ever get
training about how to separate yourself
emotionally from the things that you
have to do at work
you have some old lovely lady who comes
in one day
she's fine the next day she's blue the
next day she's dead
and you watch this unfold in front of
you
and i think there's a parallel to draw
that that they see it as
well this is my job there are some
inputs there are some processes and
there's some outputs that i need to make
with it but on the flip side i have some
friends who
on the verge of leaving or decided to
leave or sometimes get troubled by the
fact that
there is a there's an emotional layering
on top of the job and um yeah it
oddly it makes me feel it makes me feel
warm towards the physics community that
the
those guys yourself included are having
to pay this
existential price internally
in order to further our understanding of
how the physical world works
well i deeply appreciate your empathy
for us uh and i say that seriously
but i would also say that i think i
don't know if it's an occupational
hazard
or a selection mechanism
i i would not call physicists the most
introspective
of human beings and again i hate to
generalize because there are some that
are deeply introspective
um obviously i didn't know einstein i
only know einstein through
his writings um and some of his writings
suggest that he
was deeply introspective now the way he
he lived his life and the way he treated
some of his companions and his female
companions
suggests that there was a a disconnect
between the introspection that perhaps
allowed him to be deeply philosophical
about the universe
and the introspection that would have
made him a a
better human being in a more
conventional sense
so so it's hard to know um but i i've
had so many students
for whom this is just math and it's just
calculations
and they would have no patience for for
thinking deeply about what these ideas
might mean to them as a human being or
what it might mean to their place in
some
grand cosmological sense and certainly
my colleagues you know i've got some
colleagues i'm at columbia university
some who
are very open to these more expansive
conversations and some who would just
roll their eyes
if we were to head into anything that
had to do with an emotional response
to to our understanding of the oh come
on give me a break would be
be their their kind of response and
that's fine
it takes all sorts to make a community a
rich and vibrant
community i'm certainly more on the on
the end of
of willing to talk about the emotional
response to these ideas i mean i mean
the reason i wrote the book
is because for my whole life i've been
experiencing
an emotional reaction to the deep ideas
of quantum mechanics and and cosmology
and that felt the need to put down on
paper a kind of journey
a journey of a physicist who is open to
philosophical ideas who's open to
psychological ideas open to artistic and
emotional ideas because to me the
richest way to be
in the world is to hear all these voices
and to participate in all these
conversations
but i would not say that that's a
dominant perspective
among my colleagues so we talked about
the
matter and we've talked about the minds
where how where does the leap come here
to get to meaning and why did you decide
to put meaning into the book
well i don't see how you can
think deeply about these ideas without
at least having an urge for them to
inform
some sense of meaning or purpose
and what has become so clear to me
over many many decades but i felt like i
sharpened it
in articulating it in in a written form
in the book
is that well it's an idea that's old i'm
not
claiming any kind of novelty in the idea
that i'm about to mention but i
certainly felt like i got
to it through a novel trajectory
a cosmological trajectory and it's
simply the the idea
that there is no fundamental notion of
meaning
in reality in the world there's no
fundamental notion of
purpose there's no fundamental notion of
value
all reality is is collections of
particles governed by quantum mechanical
laws that evolve
from one configuration in the early
universe to a different configuration in
the late universe and
in between there's a moment when those
particles come together
and they look like human beings on one
particular remote planet in a
nondescript galaxy
and when you think about things in those
terms it can take to that dark place
or it can take you to a place of great
appreciation
and a place of gratitude because when
you realize
how unlikely it is that collections of
particles would come together to yield a
living system called a human being
and how spectacular it is that this
collection of particles called a human
being
can invent manufacture notions of value
and meaning
and purpose how spectacular is that
that particles can do that and when you
think about things in those terms
you recognize that there is a sense of
gratitude that we should all have
for the mere fact of existence and to go
beyond that
the spectacular fact that we can do
things like
create beauty and understand the
universe and illuminate
mystery and experience wonder and the
fact that particles can do
all that i feel strongly if you take it
in fully
can fill me and certainly i think can
fill others with that sense of
thankfulness
for existence however fleeting
that existence may be and if you can get
to that point
i feel that it can really change your
perspective on the world
and i've seen this with students i teach
my book
to students in fact i was teaching it
before it was a book
and the book emerged you know from you
know all that kind of
thought and experience and i have
students you know
in the classroom who come to me and say
that this has been a very different
experience from say organic chemistry
or even from you know english literature
or from psychology because this
can be a life-changing perspective and
i've seen it happen
and it's the most gratifying moment to
me when i see students
come to that realization it's so
counter isn't it to the way that we
as humans first phenomenologically as an
individual
experience our day-to-day
moment-to-moment existence of the world
it feels like it's bestowed
with specialness like there's curses and
blessings that come from on high
and we have these all manner of
different things going it feels like
more than just matter interacting with
mata and then
yeah when you layer on top of that the
fact that we have cultural artifacts
that are coming in
you have these stories that you've been
told we're dispensing with
some of us are dispensing with religion
now and the the stories that
that had attached to it and there's
people that are into astrology and
there's people that are into all manner
of different
different ways to be in the world and
um it's interesting to think
that by getting rid of all of the things
that add
narrative and personify
our experience in that way that put it
into sort of human language
that actually there's potentially even
more beauty
to say that i am just mata interacting
with mata
and that's even more special
yeah i i agree with that and the only
caveat that i would include in there is
for those who feel that
certain narratives are
absolutely vital to their appreciation
of their world
and their lives for those who want to
embrace
the theological accounts or those who
who find
that that propels them to a better place
i'm all for that i'm not of the new
atheist
community perspective that the goal is
to wipe
say one particular narrative the
religious narrative off the faces of the
earth
i do see that narrative as a natural
outcome
of the cosmological progression that
through evolution and entropy gave rise
to living systems
that themselves reflected back on their
existence and sought to place that
within a larger story we are
storytellers that's what we do
and among the largest of stories we tell
are these religious narratives
that imagine that the end is not the end
that imagine that there is a larger
purpose that is coming to us from on
high
i don't subscribe to that perspective
but i see the power and the value
of that perspective and so i like to
think about reality as these
layered narratives to use the language
that you were mentioning a moment ago
where you've got the of story that the
physicist comes along with and the
the chemist comes along with trying to
build larger structures and the
biologist puts those together into
larger structures still
and then you come along to the
psychologist the neuroscientist the
philosopher the artist
the theologian these are all these
layered accounts of reality
and i think we as individuals have the
power to
figure out which of those narratives are
most compelling to us which of those
narratives give
us a clearer sense of who we are and how
we came to be
and use those narratives to invent
our own sense of purpose and meaning
because in the end
we are the authors of whatever purpose
and value and meaning that we ascribe to
it comes ultimately from ourselves and
we have the power to pick and choose
among those stories or to invent new
ones
in order to give us that sense of
grounding
i love that i absolutely love that can
you talk to
just how finely tuned our universe is
there's a way in which is incredibly
finely tuned because what we have found
in recent decades is that if you were to
change any of the fundamental numbers
of reality that we have measured and
these are really concrete numbers like
the mass of the electron the mass of the
proton the charge of the electron
the strength of gravity those are all
numerical values that we have measured
and it turns out that if you change them
by even a small percent some of these
numbers
the universe as we know it simply goes
away stars don't light
up for instance if you start to play
with the
strength of the electromagnetic force
and the nuclear forces
and without stars right the universe as
we know it would be a completely
different place
so some have come to the conclusion that
there must be some guiding force
during the universe that carefully
adjusted
all of these numbers to have just the
right value
for stars to light up planets to form
and on at least one such planet life to
exist
others however have a of a different
perspective they say look
you know um maybe there are many
universes
as you and i were talking about earlier
in this conversation
and maybe those other universes have
different values for those numbers
and among the collection of all
universes effectively all values
are represented and only in some of
those universes will
stars and planets and people exist and
of course we live in one of those
universes because we're people
and therefore there's nothing fine-tuned
at all when you look at the
larger landscape of this multiverse of
this reality that has multiple universes
so those are sort of two ends of the
spectrum our universe is highly tuned
maybe some god-like being
picked it to be the way it is or every
possibility is out there and we simply
inhabit
that part of the larger reality that
allows us to exist
is that the observation selection effect
in a sense it is because clearly we
couldn't
observe one of those other universes
where
the conditions were such that we
couldn't exist so you could say of
course we're going to observe
a universe that has the particular
numbers that we've seen because
we couldn't exist in any other universe
and therefore we couldn't be there to
observe the different values
so yeah it's definitely an extreme
version of that idea
just how fine are we talking like
how much of a knife edge are the numbers
on it depends which number and it also
depends on
some assumptions so there are certain
numbers and i wish i could rattle off
precisely which ones and what percent
off the top my head but i'll probably
get it wrong so i won't do it
but there are numbers like the strength
of the electromagnetic force and nuclear
force where it's just a few percent or
call 10 difference would really uh
render inoperable the processes that
give rise to
the things that we are familiar with
however there have been papers recently
that have shown sure if you just change
one
number then yeah you can mess things up
and that may
make it seem finely tuned but if you
allow all
of the numbers to vary they say like
there are all these islands
of possibilities that would yield
systems that are not so different from
the ones that we are familiar with
and so it can be misleading they say to
just look at one
dimension one direction of change
because that makes it seem more special
than it actually is
um so so it's somewhat up in the air
exactly how
special it is but the fact is you know
if you were to randomly choose all those
numbers if i had like 20 dials here that
you could change
those numbers at at random i believe
that
it's unlikely that you'd hit upon one
just randomly that would be like the
universe that we know
it's crazy when you think i'm trying to
drive home the
meaning in a rationalist world point
basically that the unlikeliness of our
existence
cosmologically individually genetically
whatever it might be is so so vast i did
a i did a tedx talk
um at the start of last month and looked
at some research
that worked out to the likelihood of
your specific combination of genetics
existing
and it works out that the numbers one in
ten to the power of two million six
hundred and eighty five thousand
um which is obscenely large it's a
ridiculously large number
um and then when you think okay and
that's within
a universe where the
cosmological constant is this and the
gravity force and blah blah blah
and you just realize that there is an
awful lot to kind of be thankful for and
i understand why it gives people
i think ore and dread a kind of
they kind of sort of dance in tandem a
little bit with this
that i i can't believe how rare it is
and oh my god i can't believe how rare
it is at the same time
it terrifies you at the same at the same
moment
no no totally in fact there's another
way of framing the
the unlikeliness i mean one way is as
you say
just look at the sequence of letters in
your dna
and figure out how many possible
sequences of letters of dna and you've
got three billion base pairs
each of which you know could be one of
four letters or a lot of combinations
um but another way of looking at it is
we are the end product of a series of
quantum processes that stretch all the
way back to the big bang
because that's all that reality is it's
a series of quantum processes
and in quantum mechanics there are many
possible outcomes in any given
quantum process so each and every
event that has happened from the big
bang until today is an event that could
have turned out differently
and those different outcomes of those
quantum events
would yield a different reality when you
look at the
long sequence of events that stretch
back to the big bang
and reach until today and so right there
you've got just a gargantuan number
of possible trajectories that the
universe could have followed
that would not result in say you and i
having this conversation
right now you and i not even being here
so
so there is a great deal to be thankful
for
when you frame it in the dna approach or
the quantum processes
approach it it just so it's so unlikely
that we would be here and it'd be so
unlikely
that we would be able to even think
about
the sequence of events that result in us
being here right i mean if a
if an asteroid hadn't slammed into the
earth 65 million years
ago it could still be that the dinosaurs
would be
the dominant species walking around and
who knows maybe the dinosaurs would have
evolved to a place of self-reflection
i think it's unlikely right you know um
and so and so right there again you see
how
that chance event astrophysical event
was vital to changing the course of
how life evolved on our planet allowing
mammals to take over and
allowing through other chance events our
species to
to prevail and to take the form that it
currently does
so all of it suggests that it is so
unlikely that we would be here having
this conversation be so unlikely that
there'd be
libraries full of reflections on what
life is and how life came to be
that yeah if you if you take that all in
you can do
nothing else but stare and wonder at the
fact that we're here at all
beautiful given the fact that it's so
rare given the fact that
our appearance on this planet and there
being a planet
is so unlikely what are your thoughts
with regards to us moving forward
like how likely is it do you think that
we make it to space fairing civilization
level given that it's so rare that feels
almost like an imperative
for us until we answer the fermi paradox
we potentially are the only corner of
the universe which is lit up with its
own self-awareness which means that we
have a duty and i know
nick bostrom talks about um is it the
the waste of our
galactic potential basically every
moment that we're not spending
colonizing the galaxy is a is a waste as
far as he's concerned do you think about
that do you think about our potentials
for future
i i do and i've read some of of
nick's writing on this i i do see it a
little bit differently
um i don't see a temporal
pressure like i don't feel like we got
to get out there
we got to start spreading you know life
i don't sort of feel it that way but i
do
feel the weight of responsibility which
is at the root of of what nick is
talking about and what i'm
talking about you're talking about there
is
a sense of let's not squander
what the universe has been able to do at
least once and maybe only once
which is to have living systems that can
reflect back on the universe
understand the universe and take that
understanding
and begin to manipulate the universe to
control
aspects of the universe let's not
squander that
in the way that we clearly have
and are right i mean i wouldn't say
it's a waste of every moment that we
don't start
our journey to the stars but i would say
it's a waste of
every jewel that's j-o-u-l-e every unit
of energy
that we expend on building weapons
that we expend on war that we expend on
killing
each other that's the astounding waste
that's the profound
waste and and i think it's our
responsibility
as as thinking individuals who think
this way to try to
spread the word to the rest of our
brethren
our brothers and sisters that we
have this incredible opportunity
that emerged from this incredible
sequence of events
to to reach out to the wider universe
and to understand more fully and to
to seek other life and see what's out
there i think
if people could just be inculcated with
the thrill
of that possibility and the weight of
that responsibility
then i think things in principle could
change but of course
we're like infinitely far away from that
on planet earth at the moment
and so you know some of us you know the
conversations that you're having
books that i and others are writing i
mean it's all geared toward
trying to spread the wonder of these
ideas and so
we just keep going and hopefully we'll
be successful
it's only in the ignorance
of the unlikeliness of our existence and
the potential existential threats that
we have that can stop our continuation
plus the hubris that allows us to
believe that we can continue to just
wrangle stuff around us that i think
anybody could
consider it not our duty our imperative
to be focused on this
um it's such a shame i often think about
this i had this discussion with uh
existential risk guy i don't think
that you would be able to find a
civilization out there in the universe
that is much more emotional than we are
i think that if you turned our emotional
um set point up to be more reactive by
maybe 10 to 20 percent
i i don't think we get anything done
which is crazy
because that that that suggests that
we're close to the upper bound
of how emotional uh slightly 0.7
on the kardashev scale civilization
could be
how insane is that to think it is an
interesting way of framing it
and i'd say it becomes even more
interesting when you look at the other
end of the scale
i feel that if we were significantly
less
emotional that we would be
that much less successful as a species
because if you were a spock-like
species say from planet vulcan and
your take on reality was all about
logic and all about having
a completely unemotional interpretation
of the facts of the world and processing
them through a rational
logical perspective i don't think that
that species if that were us i don't
think we would have gotten to this place
i don't know that we would have been
able to
spread across the world i don't know
that we would have been able to
invent the things that ultimately have
transformed
modern civilization in the ways that
they have i think it's the
creative spirit the the ingenuity the
innovation that comes
from not approaching the world in a
completely
irrational way that has allowed us to
come upon
unexpected discoveries and unexpected
developments i mean even just take
albert einstein as a case in point
right if einstein was just taking a
purely logical rational
approach to things i don't know that he
would have had the leap of imagination
that gave rise to the special theory of
relativity and the general theory of
relativity and the
and the photoelectric effect is 1905
paper i mean
he was a bundle of emotion
that had access to this powerful
rational
intelligence and it's the union of the
two
that i think has been the source of our
of our success you're right too much
emotionality
whatever we'd be at each other's throats
even more than we are
right now and we wouldn't have been able
to make any progress
much less than that i don't think that
we would have gotten to the place that
we
we currently have so so if you're right
and emotional beings are kind of rare in
the cosmos
maybe it'll be either a kind of boring
galactic
exploration we're like oh yeah it's
another rational civilization on this
planet you know
that's another spot what are we doing
out here yeah this is like awful
or or they just will never develop to
the point where we'll even be able to
have that kind of communication
something tells me that our capacity for
emotion
is directly proportional to the amount
of enjoyment and utility
that we get from the thought of
exploration and from exploration itself
the goal is not simply to exist when
nick talks about
the trillions and trillions of potential
future human lives he's talking about
the utility that they could get the
the flourishing the eudaimonia the
happiness that they could experience if
we
go on for x number of million trillion
years
so it's not about just existing it's not
about just exploring
it's about using the our capacity to
experience exploration to enjoy it
and um yeah that's that's interesting
that it's
it's both the poison and the tonic yeah
and and again i can give you a concrete
example with with einstein again so
in november of 1915 as einstein's
heading toward the general theory of
relativity right that's the final month
of of research and work he
he's going at it day and night day and
night because there's a competitor named
david hilbert who he learns is hot on
his
tail now a completely rational logical
being would be like well it doesn't
matter
who discovers this it's just we want to
get to a deeper understanding
and wouldn't have worked anywhere near
as hard as einstein did and maybe
wouldn't have had the logical leaps that
he had in that in that final month and
at the end of that journey
he said something like you know the last
few weeks
of um exploration toward general
relativity
he says have left me exhausted but he
then said
the success is sublime
and it's that feeling of the sublime
which i think has driven so much of
human achievement and i would say to to
to underscore what you just mentioned
and also perhaps to reshade the
conversation that we were had about
nick and people needing to space
fare across the cosmos i don't think
that every human being needs to be
concerned with
extraterrestrial life i don't think that
every human being needs to
be excited about a journey to the stars
you know if you have a uh johannes
brahms who's composing you know
a spectacular symphony let brahms
compose brahms fourth symphony
brahms doesn't need to be thinking about
extraterrestrial intelligence
so so that that emotional that sublime
quality
of creation and creativity i think
that's what you want
human kind to respect and to revere and
to participate in
but it doesn't have to be all focused in
one direction
yeah i get i i again i absolutely love
that one thing that i was researching
recently
the buetta's void have you had a look at
this
i don't know what that is what is that
so it's a super void it's the largest
supervoid that's been found
yeah yeah yeah um have you had a look at
much of these supervisors
i i've not followed that at all i mean
certainly our
our understanding of cosmology is
predicated on the assumption
that on the largest of scales the
universe is homogeneous
and isotropic and the voids
have provided an interesting
way of wondering whether that's true
because the assumption is on large
enough scales the voids would average
out
together with the arena that are not
void that are full of stuff that on
average it'll all be the same is that
wrong
if that's wrong then it causes us to go
back and rethink some of our
cosmological ideas there's some awesome
youtube videos
about it absolutely fascinating i
suppose i'll have to check it
the crazy thing is it's it's massive
it's it's the biggest super void that's
been found
the the gaps are absolutely huge
but i suppose if that's just the head of
a pin
if our observable universe is the head
of a pin then perhaps that fluctuation
is so low that actually it doesn't
matter
and perhaps it still is compatible and
talking about from from the biggest
to the smallest why do you think the
planck scale exists
well um it's an interesting
mathematical fact that if you just take
certain constants
of nature that we've measured newton's
universal gravitational constant
usually called g h bar
planck's constant that speaks to the
quantum effects and c the speed of light
if you take these constants and you
combine them in just the right way
you can make the units come out to a
length and the particular length we call
the planck
length and it's a particular number 10
to the minus 33 centimeters
and so so from uh from a purely
methodological perspective we understand
why there seems to be a fundamental
length
built into the laws of physics you need
units and those units
are such that they can conspire to yield
this fundamental length scale
from a more philosophical perspective we
suspect it's because
the laws of physics as we understand
them only work
down to a particular length scale as we
probe the universe on ever shorter
scales we've encountered
newer and unexpected phenomenon
but it's possible that the very notion
of a smaller length
doesn't always make any sense there may
come a length
where the notion of a smaller length is
a concept that doesn't mean
anything any longer and if that
idea if that chain of reasoning is true
then that is another rationale for the
plank length the plank length would be
that length
below which the notion of below which
doesn't mean anything
and and so if there is such a length the
plank length would be it
it's so cool i saw a um
a theory online where someone said that
the reason the plank length
exists is because we're in a simulation
and that's the size of the pixels
that that's the smallest amount of bit
information that could be transmitted so
that's
that's why it's there i thought that was
quite a cute a cute way to put it yeah
but
whenever i hear things like that my
rejoinder to that is
but if you had a really clever
programmer
the programmer could make the sentient
beings in that simulation
think that there wasn't a plank length
because the programmer
is in control of the reality and
therefore can make this simulance
you and i think whatever the programmer
wants us to think
so i'm less convinced that real
constraints from the physical universe
necessarily have a home in a simulated
universe
or maybe he's put it in as a red herring
so that you think that brian green guy
thinks that he knows what's going on
yes so that's the other the other the
the flip side
is that the simulator can again
conjure things that have no basis in
reality
um so yeah the interplay between
physical reality and the reality that
the simulator creates that's a
that's a subtle one and i suspect it's
in the hands of the simulator in the
hands of the creator
and therefore crossing over between the
two always
feels to me suspect can you just
explain for me the copenhagen
interpretation
i really want to try and cut through
this seems to be like the woo-woo
element of physics that gets thrown
around
and is excuse for all manner of bad
thinking
can you just try and break down what it
is and what it isn't
well different people will answer this
question differently in the community
today
so it's not a fully well-defined notion
the
copenhagen interpretation but my view
and it's shared by many other physicists
as well is that look
niels bohr who was one of the founding
pioneers of quantum physics who was
working in copenhagen
had a particular attitude about quantum
mechanics and
any interpretation of quantum mechanics
that captures that
attitude is what we call the copenhagen
approach and his attitude was
quantum mechanics is not about
describing the universe as it
is this is almost a quote of his quantum
mechanics
is about describing the universe as it
is it's all about just making
predictions for what we'll see on
devices on counters
on on measures on instruments
so bohr was basically don't think about
the meaning of quantum mechanics don't
think about the deep nature of reality
just think about quantum mechanics as a
tool
and as a tool you should just use it to
make predictions about
the world and and so he viewed quantum
mechanics as a mathematical algorithm
follow these steps and we can teach
these steps to any undergraduate even
high school kids we can teach them
follow these steps
and it will yield a number and then
compare that number with what number you
get on a dial
and that to me is the most concrete form
of the copenhagen interpretation now
others will say
things like no the copenhagen
interpretation is about you know
you look at an experiment and that
causes the
quantum mechanical wave function to
collapse
onto this result or that result and
therefore it's all about an
uh interrelationship between an observer
and the observed
ah yeah i get it some people will say
that
but i don't think bohr ever really felt
that he'd gotten to grips
with that relationship and so i think
the the most
um accurate description of the
copenhagen approach bohr's approach is
just use quantum mechanics as an
algorithm don't worry about what it
means
perfect i think we've fixed a lot of bad
thinking with that brian today's been
fantastic i really appreciate having you
on we will be linking
the brand new paperback version of until
the end of time
in the show notes below anything else
where should people go if they want to
keep up to date with what you're doing
oh well we're doing a lot of stuff with
my organization called the world science
festival creating all sorts of
programming so yeah
people check out worldsignsfestival.com
sign up it's all free
some really cool signs programming
coming down the pike perfect
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you enjoy the conversation
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace